okay so we have got some more details on
the Babylon 5 animated movie that's
happening first of all we have a full
title Babylon 5 the road home and we
have a little bit of a synopsis we have
Sheridan being voiced by Bruce boxleiter
who played him on the show
um basically getting caught up in some
kind of time travel Shenanigans and
being thrown into alternate timelines
and trying to find his way back and over
the course of that encountering people
from his past which is how the rest of
the cast is going to fit in presumably
now they've got pretty much all the
major surviving uh actors coming back
they are also going to have the uh
characters whose actors have passed be
in it but they are getting voice actors
to do sound alike so despite the actors
having passed we will still have
Garibaldi jakar and a number of others
uh
zathras is listed I'm excited for that
right now my one big overriding question
is what's the animation style because
that might be the make or break for me
but I'm liking what I'm hearing so far